quand est-ce que vous avez un amour
secret qui en fait un petit tour de
table rapide benjamin castaldi tous les
amours vous avez là ça va pour l'instant
ça va je me suis calmé vous les dents
mais ce que vous aviez eu un amour
secret un show vous avez jamais vu
jamais dit genre une parenté à oui bah
déjà dit mcdowell
bah si tu es puisque c'est le dépasse
comme ça c'est plus que pas secret voici
frescobaldi banon mais j'ai vu de près
quand même quoi vraiment vous quand vous
avez pêchons andy macdowell on a je
voulais raconter déjà parce qu'on
n'arrive pas y croire
tu vas live et naïma chaussures ronald
mcdonald quand même jour avec l'ajout
ballon et fait cloner sa sévère mais ça
a duré très peu de temps en fait tous
les branchements pascal man
non mais c'est vrai que c'est bizarre
dès qu'une fille qui couche avec vous
une boucle de 7 minutes
ah oui elle trouve la clé de la porte ça
durait très peu de temps j'étais très
vexé en fait déjà marié avec ce que vous
avez déjà vu un amour secret amour
secret femme d'à côté stéphanie arden
qui jouent et éclat j'avais 15 16 ans
c'est vrai qu'elle est bien inspiré le
sames vous voulez pas chaud bah non non
mais on a pêché au boitier je peux dire
que non non non non ont pécho d'ailleurs
alors et alors moi même et je te dire
non mais je vous ai pape avec
isabelle je sais je sais qu'ici
bersinger taureau
[Applaudissements]
tablez vous ai gagné parce que je n'ai
pas ils sont tous vous années 3,4 et
vous vous laissez tomber du douaisis
gaye qui vous avez pécho que vous avez
siobhan vous savez le prof de ski de ma
chance ça vous les connaissez n'y a pas
de secret que malthus goût ballon genève
est et se crée donc moi je suis coeur
d'artichaut et je balance tout et après
je pêche à j'ai pas eu d'échec d'akbou
avec une star hollywoodienne
tu as une star je suis donc on est au
bout du fil c'est nous
belle mais elle ne le savait pas c'était
la nsa jones à il ya dix ans lorsqu'elle
venait à changer à la première music
hall 3 y avait eu des échanges un peu
longue ou re et c'est quoi des échanges
vigoureux en effet comme ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
quand tu bloques c'est le regard au
moins 3 4 secondes
j'estime que je dis quelque chose à mon
avis tu dois passer désuet c'était mon
ami vous a pris pour la semaine du
cheval c'est qu'elle les aime bien vous
ah oui laurence que j'ai rencontré en
seconde c'est 8 à savigny sur orge et
grâce à vos équipes
je suis amoureux d'elle depuis tout
petit grâce à ces salades ou est elle le
nom grâce à vos équipes on la retrouve
et laurence et on air proposé de me
rencontrer
jamais de la vie elle a laissé de très
bons souvenirs
vous me l'avez vous avez dormi avec
bernard montiel flatter nos verts ale et
bombardé vous diront peut-être des vieux
machins sa bronze en point et ça des
bronzes manquement à huy
vous verrez du matin au soir ça
disparaîtra oui alors n'ont jamais eu
tort d'avoir des amours secrètes ça
m'intéresserait beaucoup m'a très bien
vous bout alors moi je vais vous dire
j'ai couché avec tous les gens que
j'aimais à bon entendeur
alors moi j'ai juste après que vous dire
salut les hommes mais je sais avant
d'essayer gore et grichka bon alors moi
je n'entends pas pour ceux qui veulent
venir chercher la personne
un numéro azur qui va s'afficher au bas
de votre écran font venir la chercher
avant 20h dit allez vas-y alors alors
quoi dans ces bandes avait dit alors
c'est qui non mais secret lourd secret
anon secrète on prend le front ça n'a
rien il entend mal alors vous y'a
quelqu'un que j'aime bien maintenant
mais qui sait pas que j'aime bien quoi à
mon secret y'a pas que vous aimez bien
en ce moment on ne dit rien qui vaille
est celle où j'ai déclaré je le fais ma
flamme
ah non non photo de quoi france
maintenant c'est un ami toi il voit
arriver les gars ben ouais nom le prénom
le prénom christian question je sais qui
c'est l'équivalent non ces questions
dior
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais le g8 à l'aller grâce à qui avec
marc et cd de succès sur ai dit vous
savez c'est sûr que c'est lui question
c'est christian et il le sait bamako
savoir arrêter là non pas de suite il à
la télé je pense pas que rihanna télé à
cette heure belge et le trouver et les
impôts de 6 mais en fait vous c'est
juste un ami vous aimeriez son ami c'est
fou comme bénin avec moi ouais pareil
danser et alors vous à moi j'en ai eu
des amours secrets mais je sais pas
gardée secrète donc je vais aller voir à
chaque fois je me prenais des râteaux
donc une très belle anecdote
moi j'ai un amour secret c'est un
américain c'est un chanteur fin mais je
sais qui c'est justin bieber ah bah non
il m'a jamais envoyé de signaux ces qui
s'est passé sur le plateau il n'ya pas
longtemps sait qui c'est le mec des
black eyed peas mais ouais
[Applaudissements]